Avant de commencer cette vidéo,
vous avez bien compris qu'on va parler
de psychopathes et de ce qu'il y
a dans la tête d'un psychopathe.
Donc des choses peuvent vous choquer
dans les anecdotes, dans les choses
que je vais raconter sur Ted Bundy.
Si vous n'aimez pas ça ou si vous êtes
trop jeune, n'hésitez pas
à ne pas regarder cette vidéo.
Salut, aujourd'hui,
on va se mettre dans la peau d'un
profiler et comprendre ce qui se
passe dans la tête d'un tueur en série.
Pourquoi certaines personnes
deviennent des criminels?
Est ce qu'il y a une influence
de l'enfance pour ça?
Ou est-ce qu'on naît criminel?
Ou est-ce qu'on le devient?
Est ce que tous les psychopathes
deviennent forcément des tueurs en série?
Ça pourrait peut être vous
servir dans la vie de savoir ça.
Genre, si votre patron ou votre conjoint
est un dangereux psychopathe,
alors, accrochez vous.
Aujourd'hui, je vous dis tout.
Les tueurs en série,
c'est un sujet qui est très complexe et je
ne pourrais pas aborder toutes
les facettes dans cette vidéo.
Déjà, parce que je ne suis pas un expert
en criminologie clairement,
mais aussi parce qu'il y a
une immensité de cas de figure.
C'est pour ça que je vais m'appuyer
sur une histoire, celle de Ted Bundy,
pour illustrer tout ça.
Commençons par le début.
C'est toujours une bonne chose.
À quel moment on qualifie
une personne de tueur en série?
C'est quand la personne en question commet
au moins trois meurtres dans un intervalle
qui peut aller de quelques
jours à plusieurs années.
Et c'est le cas de Ted Bundy.
Vous en avez déjà peut
être entendu parler.
Cet Américain a été condamné
pour les meurtres d'une trentaine
de femmes dans septs Etats différents,
plus précisément 36 femmes,
selon ses propres déclarations.
En réalité, les enquêteurs pensent qu'il
s'agit plutôt d'une centaine de victimes.
D'apparence, Ted Bundy était quelqu'un
de charmant, de séduisant,
de charismatique, d'intelligent.
Le genre de personne qui a tout pour lui.
On se serait jamais douté une seule
seconde qu'il serait capable
de commettre les pires atrocités.
Son mode d'action était le suivant : il
approchait ses victimes dans des lieux
publics et il faisait mine d'être
handicapé ou un peu blessé.
Il demandait de l'aide pour l'amener à sa
voiture jusqu'à entraîner ses victimes
dans un endroit plus isolé
pour ensuite les agresser et les tuer.
Ça va même plus loin puisqu'il serait
revenu sur les lieux du crime
pour commettre des actes sexuels
sur les cadavres en quasi décomposition.
On appelle ça de la nécrophilie.
C'était un excellent manipulateur
qui savait user de ses charmes
pour gagner la confiance de ses victimes.
La grande question, c'est :
comment une personne peut arriver
à commettre de telles horreurs?
Est-ce qu'il y a une prédisposition
génétique ou est-ce que c'est
dû à des traumatismes?
La question est très complexe et ça fait
des années que les psychologues essaient
d'y répondre de façon claire et précise.
Ce qu'ils ont souvent constaté,
c'est que les tueurs en série viennent
en majorité de familles brisées où le père
est absent et où la mère
prend une place importante.
Patrick Mullany, qui était agent spécial
et instructeur à l'Académie du FBI,
explique que lorsqu'un enfant n'a pas
connu l'influence d'un père,
il peut y avoir un rejet de la mère.
Quand il passe à l'acte,
c'est comme s'il cherchait à punir sa mère
en faisant du mal à ses
victimes innocentes.
Cela reste bien sûr un cas de figure
parmi d'autres.
Chez Ted Bundy, il y aurait bien quelque chose
de cet ordre là, puisqu'il a vécu
une enfance très perturbante.
Il est né en 1946 et n'a
jamais connu son père.
Sur son acte de naissance,
il était noté que son père s'appelait
Lloyd Marshall, un vétéran de l'armée.
Mais sa mère aurait finalement avoué plus
tard que le père était un marin
prénommé Jack Worthington.
Mais personne n'a jamais trouvé
de trace de ces deux hommes.
Il était plutôt supposé que son
grand-père aurait abusé de sa mère au final.
Ted a vécu à Philadelphie,
dans la maison de ses grands-parents
maternels, qui l'ont élevé
comme si c'était leur fils.
Il faut savoir que la mère de Ted Bundy
est tombée enceinte sans être mariée
et à cette époque, c'était très mal vu
de tomber enceinte avant le mariage.
Du coup, pour cacher cette grossesse soi
disant illégitime qui était
donc possiblement un inceste,
on a fait croire à Ted que ses grands
parents étaient ses parents
et que sa mère était sa grande sœur.
Est ce que vous arrivez à imaginer
dans quel mensonge il a vécu?
Pour l'anecdote, un jour,
la tante de Ted faisait la sieste
et lorsqu'elle s'est réveillée,
elle avait tout autour d'elle
plein de couteaux de cuisine.
Ted était là, devant elle.
Il souriait en voyant ça.
Il n'avait que 3 ans et c'était vraiment
lui qui avait fait ça... Déjà très chaud.
Et c'est seulement à l'adolescence qu'il a
découvert tous les mensonges
qui gravitaient autour de lui quand son
cousin l'a traité de bâtard en lui
montrant son acte de naissance.
Il en a voulu toute sa vie
à sa mère de lui avoir menti.
Et à l'âge de 20 ans,
Ted subit une déception amoureuse
qu'il vit très très mal.
Et c'est peut être la goutte d'eau qui va
être un élément déclencheur
pour le faire passer à l'acte.
Ted commet quelques actes de délinquance,
des vols de voitures,
des cambriolages, etc.
Il commence clairement à déconner.
Et en parallèle de ça,
les autorités s'inquiètent
de la disparition de nombreuses jeunes
filles qui, les unes après les autres,
ne donnent plus aucun signe de vie.
Plus de nouvelles.
Une réelle disparition.
La police enquête
et la police finit par trouver un lien
entre Ted Bundy et la disparition
de ces jeunes filles.
Ils interpellent Ted Bundy
et l'incarcère, mais il s'évade à deux
reprises et se fait interpeller
de nouveau pour de bon en 1978.
Pour terminer, il est exécuté en 1989
dans la prison de Raiford, en Floride.
Mais du coup, vous allez me dire : pourquoi
il y a des personnes qui vivent
des enfances très difficiles et qui ne
deviennent pas des tueurs
en série pour autant?
Pourquoi, dans une famille,
il y a un enfant qui va mal tourner
et l'autre va réussir à s'en sortir?
Alors qu'ils ont vécu le même contexte?
Eh bien, en fait,
c'est un mix de plusieurs choses.
Il y a une prédisposition génétique
associée à des traumatismes.
Une étude a été menée
par les scientifiques de l'Université
d'Albuquerque et de
l'Université de Chicago.
Les chercheurs ont analysé le cerveau
de 808 prisonniers, âgés de 33
ans en moyenne grâce à un IRM.
Trois groupes distincts ont été créés.
Tout d'abord, les meurtriers : 203 personnes.
Ensuite, ceux qui n'ont pas commis
d'homicide, mais qui sont quand même jugés
très violents:  475 personnes. Pour terminer,
les délinquants non-violents : 130 personnes.
Les personnes avec des troubles mentaux
n'ont pas été intégrées dans l'étude
pour éviter de biaiser les résultats.
En résumé, il y aurait une différence
entre le cerveau d'un meurtrier
et les deux autres groupes.
L'étude explique que les réductions
de matière grise chez les délinquants
condamnés pour homicide étaient évidentes
dans un certain nombre de zones
du cerveau, qui sont des zones importantes
pour le traitement affectif,
la cognition sociale et le contrôle
comportemental stratégique.
Ça veut dire quoi?
Ça signifie qu'il y aura un impact
sur la prise de décision, l'empathie
et le sentiment de culpabilité.
Cela confirme l'étude d'ailleurs d'Adrian
Raine, un psychologue et professeur
en criminologie, qui affirme qu'il y a
une différence entre le cerveau d'un
meurtrier et le cerveau d'une personne dite normale.
Il a comparé l'activité cérébrale
de meurtriers et de non meurtriers.
Qu'est-ce qu'il a vu en faisant ça?
Il a remarqué que les cerveaux des tueurs
en série avaient une activité cérébrale
plus forte dans le cortex préfrontal,
zone qui joue un rôle dans les troubles de
l'humeur, mais pas seulement. L'amygdale,
le siège de l'émotion était plus petite que la normale.
Cette zone était physiquement réduite de 18%.
C'est très significatif.
Le plus cocasse dans cette histoire,
c'est que le professeur qui a mené cette
étude a lui même cet amygdale
plus petite que la normale.
Mais la différence,
c'est qu'il est né dans une famille
aimante où il a grandi de façon épanouie
et ne s'est pas tourné vers le crime.
Donc, cela signifierait que la combinaison
entre des facteurs internes
et des traumatismes provenant
de l'extérieur pourrait rendre
une personne plus à même de commettre
des atrocités et de ne
pas culpabiliser pour ça.
Les neuro criminologues affirment
effectivement que la cause
n'est pas uniquement innée.
Les facteurs sont donc aussi externes,
comme la socialisation,
l'éducation, des abus sexuels, etc.
Il serait alors simple de supposer que
Ted Bundy entrerait dans ce cas de figure.
Et pourtant, exception à la règle.
Après avoir été exécuté, des expériences ont été
menées sur son cerveau pour voir s'il y
avait d'éventuelles lésions, mais son
cerveau serait tout à fait dans la norme.
Rien de particulier. Par contre,
ted Bundy avait le comportement
d'un psychopathe. Un psychopathe,
c'est quelqu'un qui, de prime abord,
paraît totalement normal.
La réalité, c'est qu'il est dépourvu
d'empathie et de toute culpabilité.
Du coup, c'est très grave parce que ça
signifie que, quoi qu'il fasse,
il ne va ressentir aucune émotion.
Il ne va pas mesurer
la conséquence de ses actes.
C'est un vrai trouble sévère
de la personnalité puisque du coup,
le fait qu'on ressente pas d'émotions,
et bien, on n'arrive pas à percevoir
les différences entre le bien et le mal,
puisqu'on n'a pas les sentiments associés
qui permettent de se dire : je ne suis pas
à l'aise avec ce que je fais ou
c'est trop bien ce que je
suis en train de vivre.
On est beaucoup trop neutre.
Un psychopathe peut donc avoir
des comportements imprévisibles,
des conduites addictives.
Ce sont des personnes qui ont du mal
à maintenir les relations et surtout,
ce sont des gens qui ont
horreur de la frustration.
Quand ils n'ont pas ce qu'ils veulent,
ils peuvent partir dans une colère
noire extrêmement rapidement.
Ted Bundy n'avait aucun remords.
Il ne ressentait pas d'empathie et ne
mesurait vraisemblablement pas
les conséquences de ses actes.
A cela s'ajoute le facteur de perversité,
ce plaisir que prend
le meurtrier pendant l'acte.
Ça lui donne un sentiment
de toute puissance.
Bien sûr, tous les psychopathes
ne deviennent pas des criminels.
Ils peuvent être violents envers autrui
sans jamais passer à l'acte
ou être violent avec eux mêmes.
Mais quand ça arrive,
c'est vraiment chaud.
Pour vous donner un ordre d'idée,
on compte 3% d'hommes psychopathes
et 1% pour les femmes.
Ted Bundy souffrait aussi de paraphilie.
La paraphilie, c'est tout ce qui regroupe
des actes sexuels déviants et qui peut
impliquer une violation du consentement d'autrui.
En gros, son traumatisme d'enfance,
son trouble sexuel et sa psychopathie,
ça fait un cocktail explosif.
Par ailleurs, il y a une autre théorie
psychologique intéressante qui a été
observée par le psychiatre John MacDonald.
Il y aurait trois caractéristiques
qui permettraient de repérer si un enfant
risque de devenir un criminel ou non
à l'âge adulte. On appelle
ça la triade MacDonald.
Rien à voir avec les burgers.
Dedans, on retrouve un enfant qui tue des animaux.
Un enfant qui fait pipi au lit très longtemps
et un enfant qui met le feu
à des objets, des bâtiments.
John MacDonald considère que si l'un de ces
trois symptômes persiste après l'âge de 5
ans, il y a un risque de devenir criminel.
En faisant une étude sur une centaine de sujets,
Il a constaté que ces caractéristiques
revenaient le plus souvent.
Donc, ce n'est pas une science
exacte, mais c'est un indice.
Mais pour le coup,
c'est vraiment à prendre avec
des pincettes parce que d'autres études ne
voient aucun lien entre cette triade
et les criminels,
même si l'attitude de Ted Bundy confirme
la théorie puisqu'il tuait des animaux étant enfant.
Cette théorie est toujours intéressante à citer,
en tout cas.
Si ce genre de sujet comme cette vidéo
vous intéresse, il y a plusieurs
possibilités pour vous.
Pour continuer,
il y a des séries comme You
ou comme Mind Hunter qui sont très
intéressantes que je vous recommande.
Et puis, il y a l'éventuelle
possibilité qu'on continue cette série.
C'est à dire que ce format devienne
un nouveau format sur la chaîne
quatre, cinq fois par an,
moins, plus, je ne sais pas.
Ça, ça dépendra de vous.
Ça dépendra du nombre
de vues de cette vidéo.
On ne va pas se mentir.
Si elle ne vous plaît pas,
je ne vais pas continuer.
Et puis, ça dépendra aussi de votre
engagement dessus,
les commentaires, les like.
Donc, si vous aimez ça,
si vous en voulez d'autres, n'hésitez pas
à me le dire et surtout à me le montrer.
Le nombre de sujets connexes qu'on
pourrait faire est assez impressionnant,
aussi bien au niveau des criminels en
question que sur les grandes questions.
Par exemple, quelle est la différence
entre un psychopathe et un sociopathe?
Ça pourrait être l'épisode 2. Pour terminer,
deux choses qui devraient vous intéresser.
Tout d'abord,
si  le sujet de la manipulation
comme Ted Bundy vous intéresse au sens
large du terme, je vous recommande mon
dernier livre, L'antiguide
de la manipulation que vous avez
à côté. Le lien est dans la description.
Et enfin, la tournée de mon spectacle
Singularité continue pour se terminer.
Ce spectacle s'arrête
définitivement au mois de décembre.
Les dates en septembre, par exemple,
il y a deux spectacles en Suisse
une représentation à Lille,
une autre à Annecy, une à Saint Amand les Eaux,
une à Longjumeau, etc.
N'hésitez pas à réserver.
On se voit à la fin du spectacle,
comme d'habitude, pour les dédicaces,
les photos, tout ce que vous voulez.
Le lien est dans la description.
Je m'appelle toujours Fabien Olicard.
Merci d'avoir regardé la vidéo.
Ici, deux autres vidéos sur des sujets
un petit peu mentaux.
Prenez soin de vous, à très bientôt.
Ciao.